aye sir I certainly don't assume that
I'm going to be the only survivor who
decides to run for king of the world
there's going to be other people that
don't want me in charge it's mine that's
why I'm starting the campaign early on
national Geographics not going to be the
same channel they get to re-explore the
entire world again just with a new look
everything can be destroyed National
Geographic explorers exploring the same
thing again for the first time again see
there's a sale here but that doesn't
really matter because a few years I can
just come in and just take these roads
excuse me have you guys thought about
2012 at all it's just around the corner
don't go soda go water it's gonna last
longer it's not going to go bad the
Mayan calendar predicts that the world
will end in exactly three years december
two thousand twelve are you running for
king of the universe if so i need to
know about it because you're running
against muaz it's just around the corner
a lot of people going to want to prep
they're going to want to get into a safe
bathtub we didn't punch in the face all
right enjoy your workout I don't think
he's gonna vote for me if there is a
vote 2012 it's not just a john cusack
movie a vote for me is a vote for
post-college opportunities in the
workplace gotta have a platform Plaza
voter I want you
because if ya you survive here we have
talked you yeah me I'm a friendly face
really go for him so if the Mayans are
pranking us this is probably one of the
most amazing prints of all time I'm a
reliable source of survival I'm banking
on at most the moon explode it is hard
to get people listening up I might need
a bigger campaign than this